it's now an annual anxiety how to
conduct classes safely without making
the covet 19 pandemic worse i have two
kids under the age of five and you know
providing them with virtual schooling is
not easy and so getting them into a
school setting where they can be there
continuously over the coming school year
to me is really important fahad razak is
not just a parent he's an epidemiologist
and he's worried wastewater indicators
suggest another increase in covert 19 is
coming current levels across the country
relative to just a year ago are five to
ten times higher depending on the test
you're looking at razak says it's too
early for ontario's decision to remove
isolation requirements for those who
become infected fearing it could lead to
asymptomatic staff and students
returning to schools while still
contagious
a view shared by the union for ontario
high school teachers and other school
staff we should be celebrating right now
going back to school face to face but
it's being a little bit clouded by the
the fear around covid offsetting some of
that fear is canada approving an updated
covet 19 vaccine to target the first
highly contagious omicron variant
ontario is urging anyone with new or
worsening symptoms to stay home until
their symptoms improve for at least 24
hours
some provinces and territories are still
recommending masks in classrooms and
other crowded spaces even if they're no
longer mandatory if they're ill
especially with new cold or flu-like
symptoms that they need to stay home
and not just go off to school
and arrange for testing for coconut as
appropriate everyone is tired of the
pandemic no one wants to hear what
medical experts say remains true
that with so many swirling variables
what happens next in the covet 19
equation is impossible to figure out
ross lord global news